earlier in your algebraic careers you
learned how to multiply polynomials so
for example if we had x plus 2
times 4x plus 5 we learned that this is
the same thing as really doing the
distributive property twice but you
could multiply x times 4x to get 4 x
squared you could multiply x times 5 to
get 5x you could multiply 2 times 4x to
get 8x and you could multiply 2 times 5
to get 10 if what i just did looks
foreign to you i encourage you to review
multiplying binomials on khan academy
but then this could be simplified as
being 4x squared plus
13x plus 10.
what we will now do as we advance our
algebraic careers is to think about how
do we go the other way around how do we
divide polynomials so for example we
might see an expression like this
4x squared plus 13x plus 10
divided by
x plus 2.
now you might already know from your
knowledge of multiplication and division
that this is really reversing what we
just did up here that if x plus 2 times
4x plus 5 is equal to this business then
this business divided by x plus 2 should
be equal to 4x plus 5.
and even if you didn't have this
information that we have up here there's
ways that you would have approached this
one way is that you could have tried to
factor what we have here in the
numerator you could have said hey let me
maybe factor this by grouping i must do
that right over here 4x squared plus 13x
plus 10. when you factor by grouping you
say hey can i think of two numbers whose
product is equal to 4 times 10. so i say
a times b is equal to 40 and whose sum
is equal to 13. so a plus b is equal to
13.
and let's see what it could be
it could be eight and five
so a is equal to eight b is equal to
five this is just factoring by grouping
right over here once again if this is
unfamiliar with 2u i encourage you to
review factoring by grouping on khan
academy and so we can break apart this
13x as an 8x and a 5x so we can rewrite
this as 4x
squared plus 8x
plus 5x
plus 10
plus 10. and notice it's just re undoing
what we did up here but we're assuming
that we don't even know about what we
did up here that this someone just gave
us this this quadratic and said factor
it and then here you could say all right
for these first two terms i could factor
out a 4x so it becomes 4x times x plus 2
and then these second two terms i could
factor out a 5 so plus five
times x plus two and then i can factor
out an x plus two so it becomes
it becomes
x plus two i'll scroll down a little bit
it becomes x plus two i'm just factoring
that out
times 4x plus 5 4x
plus 5 which is exactly what we had up
there and so you could rewrite this
expression that involves divisions
sometimes called a rational expression
as
we can rewrite this
as
x plus two
times four x plus five
all of that over
x plus two and as long as x does not
equal negative 2 we can divide the
numerator and denominator by x plus 2
and we're going to be left with 4 x plus
5. and we could constrain it we could
say 4
4
x not equaling negative 2. this is just
a little bit of a primer as we go deeper
we'll do many many many examples of this
and we'll also see that there's other
techniques other than just factoring
this numerator over here and we're going
to do it with higher degree polynomials
third degree polynomials and we're going
to learn something known as polynomial
division where it's going to look an
awful lot and it's actually going to
have a lot of similarities with the long
division that you likely learned in
probably fourth or fifth grade where
we're going to take expressions like x
plus 2 and we're going to divide it into
4x squared plus 13x plus 10. instead of
place value or we'll have our a new
notion of place value which is around
which degree term you're thinking about
so we're going to do things like and
we're going to do these completely in
other videos hey how many times does x
go into 4x squared hey it goes 4x times
so you'd write the 4x there and then you
multiply 4x times x squared you get 4x
squared
4x times 2 is 8x then you subtract these
and then you keep going just like you
would typically do long division 13x
minus 8x is 5x and then you bring that
10 down and then you say hey how many
times does x go into 5x you say hey it
goes five times five times
x
is equal to five x five times two is
equal to ten
and then you subtract this and you're
left with no remainder and so notice you
just saw when x plus 2 is divided into
this you get 4x plus 5. just what we saw
right over there so we're going to
explore these multiple techniques
including polynomial division and we're
also going to see what happens when you
do have a remainder there